so
uh solutions
so how do we
i mean jp had a good point he's
basically like just don't don't yield to
it don't succumb to it um
decentralization is definitely one of
the solutions here there's a reason why
again
countries of non-profits any of the
elites have been saying for a long time
we need to ban bitcoin it's bad they're
making up [ __ ] stories like
criminals are using it also lies already
dealt with that uh decentralization is a
good thing because it removes power from
the central elite it removes power from
big banks it's permissionless i don't
need anybody's permission if i want to
send money from me to any one of you
guys in a live chat right now i can send
in a uh cryptocurrency transfer on any
number of different kinds of currencies
without anybody stopping me from doing
it there's no like giant fee you know
from the bank or waiting period of two
days or they ask me a [ __ ] survey
like where did this money like whenever
i go to the bank right now and if you
make any deposit over ten thousand
dollars because of anti-money laundering
laws and fair enough you know you don't
want uh you know criminals or you don't
want you know
sorry anti-money laundering
anti-terrorism they ask you a sequence
of questions it's like i'm getting
[ __ ] tired of answering questions
about whenever i have to make a deposit
so the easy solution that is just
deposit less than what the threshold is
right
um but they want to know everything
about well where's this money coming and
i tried to [ __ ] with them once time you
know she's like well you know i have to
put in here you know where this money's
coming from like why does it matter it's
my money well she goes well it's over
this amount so i have to put it in here
you know it's for the bank i'm like
doesn't matter it's my money why do i
need to tell you that right and we had
to go back and forth the manager gets a
vosi like you know let's just see where
this goes sort of thing they're adamant
about it so decentralization is a
important component of a solution this
problem
and
it's beyond me why most of the world has
not adopted it to this point
i mean there's not a lot of forward
thinkers and there's not a lot of guys
that are unplugged that see the code in
the matrix that know exactly what's
going on uh most people are plugged in
pleb sleep walking through life you know
for being honest so you just have to
kind of accept that reality but
um you know when it smacks you across
the forehead like a frying pan of the
forehead sort of moment like it did in
greece and cyprus and argentina when
they realized that the currency was
worth [ __ ] and they were basically
wheelbarrowing in money to weigh it like
they didn't count it they would weigh it
and set on a [ __ ] scale because it's
so
you know worthless uh and and people try
to go to the banks to get their money
out when they found the state actually
seized it that's when they're like oh
now i see a [ __ ] argument for
decentralization now i see an argument
for bitcoin but by then
you're not one of the whales you haven't
accumulated anything you've been sitting
on the sidelines like a muppet thinking
it's not important because the
government's been broadcasting this [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] news all day long telling
you that oh it's you know it's it's it's
used by criminals or it's not safe for
you know blah blah blah whatever the
narrative is
decentralization decentralization and
all see
things get censored all the time i was
watching um
so i'm flipping through you know the
youtubes the other day and i've not seen
donald trump in an interview anywhere
live for [ __ ] ages and this was on
youtube and it was a brand new podcast i
think it was called the full send
podcast some of you probably uh heard of
it or send of it or heard of it
apparently it's quite popular and um you
know it was an interview with donald
trump and i watched the whole thing it
was like 45 minutes long or something
like that and it was it was just
conversation it was just like hey you
know what are you doing what do you
think of this and all that one of the
things he said he goes you know you guys
are um going to have this video taken
down like they're going to remove this
and like nah they're not you know we've
put out tons of videos you know we're
just a friend of dana's
um dana white and you know we're mutual
friends so we introduced us so i thought
it'd be cool to have a conversation
she's like well i'm telling you right
now this is this is going to disappear
at some point in the very near future
and he was right very [ __ ] quickly
they took that [ __ ] down
um
decentralization of content i think is a
great idea and nobody's really figured
it out just yet it's gonna come
because there's people working on it
there's a lot of smart people working on
it because the cool thing about a lot of
smart people is they're mostly
libertarians and they're smart enough to
see the [ __ ] they can see through
the lies you know when they're all like
we're gonna go in there and get his
weapons of mass destruction like yeah
[ __ ] there's nothing there and
they're also like hey you know you take
take this jab and stand on this dot and
there's a pandemic blah blah blah okay
i'm not saying that you know people
didn't get sick and died i lost the
family member to the freaking kobe
[ __ ] not because of kobe but because
of [ __ ] they gave him at the hospital
i'm telling you guys you have to you
know you have to keep your eyes open and
take a look at what's going on anyway
back to the decentralization so we're
talked about that okay decent
decentralization of information of money
um ideally decentralization is a good
thing but it's going to be an uphill
battle because government doesn't want
things decentralized they want it
centralized so
if more of the population sees the value
in decentralization
i've got my nano ledger here speaking of
which got to open that up and set it up
um if if more of the population leans
into it and adopts it there's not much
the government can do about that
i mean they're still going to cram
[ __ ] down people's throats they're
still going to cram uh cbdc's they're
still going to probably cram universal
basic income they're going to cram
narratives around progressivism and
liberalism and more of the isms out
there
um it's it's it's going to keep coming
but decentralization is something that
you're going to want to look for so you
guys want solutions number one thing is
do what you can to participate in a
decentralized economy okay so we've
talked about that arm yourself number
two
um
i realize that there is a part of the
population that doesn't like you know
defending themselves they think that
it's unnecessary they want to trust in
the state or the military or the police
force or the fact that people are just
good and kind or whatever you know the
humble notion might be at the time but
the reality of the world is that humans
are warring we're violent we've been
violent for a long [ __ ] time and
we're not a peaceful
being we're just not
um we are more violent than any other
species on the planet we've killed more
of our own
we're vile disgusting things we're
scourge of the earth you know if you
want to call it that that's essentially
what humans are so thinking
thinking that
you know if i just think warm and fuzzy
and inclusivity and rainbows and
butterflies and all that sort of [ __ ]
nobody's gonna hurt me nothing bad's
ever gonna happen bad [ __ ] happens and
it happens a lot and it has happened a
lot through history and it's not going
to [ __ ] stop
and if you think just trusting your
overlords is a good thing you're going
to see how badly mistaken you are in the
future i'm going to move on from that
that's
that's just learning basic skills for
yourself and inclusive in that is
learning how to fight
how many times have you guys watched my
unplugged alpha show on monday night and
some guy calls them he's like where do i
find you know cool unplugged guys to
hang out with and chop up these ideas
and you know
up upgrade my network right first thing
i basically say to them is cool man you
know you're part of a dojo no i don't i
don't fight why not
that's that's where those guys are the
guys that are the most unplugged that
i've met anywhere are fighters whether
it's professional or amateur or anywhere
on that spectrum they either fight they
know how to fight or they're learning
how to fight
let's keep going um education
we are
there's arguments around depopulation
there's arguments around
we need more population
but what i will say as far as a solution
because i don't really [ __ ] care if
they're trying to depopulate or they're
trying to overpopulate or whatever it
isn't trying to i can't control that but
i'm talking about solutions that are
within your control and one of the
things that you should look at if you're
a parent
is homeschooling your kids or private
schooling them
they're both going to take time and
money from you which is an inconvenience
but you're going to have to accept it so
this is only going to be available to
people that are properly sorted in their
lives okay meaning they've got their
money sorted and they can afford to keep
the mother or their kids home to raise
their kids and educate them or they've
got sufficient money and resources where
they can put them in a private school
system where um they have some control
over choosing which school the kids go
into because of the curriculum that they
use and the stuff they stay away from
the stuff they lean into
all that stuff's really really important
and i think that if you're going to
raise kids and leave them up to the
state to educate you're basically
screwing yourself over you know you're
letting yourself down so put them
educate your children privately is
basically what i'm saying don't let
the state indoctrinate them with the
woo-woo [ __ ] that's pussifying the
west that's going to end up with more
state control more centralization not
decentralization
and a weaker more compliant society that
agrees to stand on dots i
truthfully believe that they thought
that this whole uh beer bug pandemic was
going to
be that for them and i think they
realized that it that it failed in fact
i've got a great clip here i got to show
you guys
um
because people woke up um when they
started to see
you know i said this earlier today on
twitter i think honestly
that joe rogan has unplugged and
repelled more people than any other uh
i'm gonna call it a creator in in
history
just because he's got the spotify deal
which essentially gives him free reign
for the most part with the exception of
the stupid apologies that he keeps
making which i don't agree with and i've
already talked about that in a prior
video but um
he's he's repelled a lot of people with
uh dr malone dr mccullough
um i can't remember the uh muslim guy
with the british accent that was talking
about all the [ __ ] that's going on as
well he's red pill a lot of people
because he's getting 40 50 60 million
views
on some of his uh podcast episodes and
uh
that's a lot that's that's way more than
the mainstream media and i think that's
that's alone and
you know god bless the guy he's doing
the right thing i think that's unplugged
a lot of people i think it's a great
thing in fact
so
decentralization again you like you know
it's it's it's going to become really
really really important i mean
you know a lot of people are like oh
elon musk is such a good guy and he's
solving problems in the world and i
really respect him for that cool you
know we're saving the polar bears and
the [ __ ] seals and all that with
electric energy but
uh i think that a bigger problem to
tackle i mean
if we're being honest electric cars just
transfer
the source of pollution from the
tailpipe to the chimney at the
coal-fired plant because that's where
most of the electricity comes from you
know for the most part it's not
windmills and solar panels that's where
it comes from
guys like elon musk i mean if they
really want to save the planet should be
investing in nuclear power for example
or um
like a decentralized social media
platform that really properly works
right that that is
that is going to get mass adoption
anyway uh where's that clip with
um
bill gates and his wife
the dude the dude that looks like his
wife there it is
um
share on screen where's my headphones
give me a second because i want you to
hear this little clip it's like five
seconds long
uh sure screen
chrome tab
boom
and
okay let's play this real quick it's
very very short
so we
you know we'll have to
prepare for the next one that
you know i'd say is uh
will get attention this time
look at the smug look on this guy's face
and this guy's face too by the way look
at the smug look on his face
he goes
we'll have to prepare for the next one
and
i'd say it'll get attention this time is
basically where he's driving at
like they're not even hiding it
and you know people are going to
criticize me oh you know you're making
mountains out of mole hills or maybe
you're interpreting i was like dude
i know people i have a very good
[ __ ] detector and i s and that reeks
of [ __ ] okay don't know if it's
constipation or diarrhea i know it's
[ __ ] though that's what i know
anyway
um
last
solution i wanted to present to you guys
again things that you can control before
i take some of these call-ins over here
i see you guys waiting let me know in
the private chat by the way those of you
that are waiting
um whether or not you want to hit on
whether you think the elites are doing
the right thing or if it's a bad thing
last thing is becoming
independent from
things that you would typically lean on
in the past
food energy um those would be the main
ones right like where are you going to
put your electricity or or get your gas
from to put it in the car that's very
hard to um
you know take control for yourself i
mean i've seen some friends of mine that
have put solar panels and you need a lot
of them today um you know to get the
amount of energy that you need to
run your household and even charge an
electric car for example you need a lot
of them and they cost a lot of money so
this isn't easily accessed by a lot of
people which again
supports the argument that i keep making
you know to you guys which some people
still get pissed off at i have no idea
why when i say you know try to be a
millionaire by the time you're 30 40 you
know the latest because it you need
financial freedom you need the ability
to make these choices and decisions like
let's say bad [ __ ] comes down the road
and you want to have control of your
energy and not rely on the government or
their rates or when they're going to
give it to you or when you can or can't
use it sort of thing and you know you
want to put solar power panels on your
house be independent that way there's a
lot of guys that i've seen
that have set up
diesel generators uh water collection
systems so they don't have to rely on
the state delivering clean drinking
water they generate their own through
rain water and purification systems they
grow their own food so they don't have
to rely on you know the supply of food
that comes via the grocery stores we've
seen a massive increase in uh prices
over the last couple years with
inflation and you know they're using
numbers here in canada like oh recently
it was determined to be like 5.7 you
know percent and it's a lot more than
that you know in the u.s they've they've
said it's something like seven or eight
percent but it's still a lot more than
that right it's a trailing number and
they're not including enough of the data
to really you know make you understand i
mean because if i go to the grocery
store and i want to get
a stock of celery to juice for myself
excuse me i think that was like buck 99
99 cents at one point you're paying like
double in some cases triple that rate so
in in the real consumables that the
average person uses ie groceries for
example you're paying a lot more so
being independent from what they can
control is a good thing it's like you
know it's part of the reason why you
don't see western leaders you know
speaking of
this conflict with russia and ukraine
and the prices of gas today as we stand
in 2022 at the end of march
they removed the ability to produce
their own energy in the west
there was a pipeline that the canadian
prime minister
basically shot down the u.s government
didn't want to approve it apparently the
democrats have recently blocked it there
was something i saw on twitter earlier
but pipelines and domestic production
have
been removed from the toolbox under the
guise of protecting the climate
now let's use the climate change
argument for a little bit let's say
they're right let's let's protect the
north american
economy and climate and the polar bears
and the seals and all this stuff here
and let's not
mine the earth because it's damaging and
you know insert that narrative okay
maybe you're right but now where does
the oil and gas come from because you
still need it you still have trucking
you still have rail you still have
shipping you still have air you still
have cars you still have heating costs
these people don't understand that has
to come from somewhere so whether you
stop making it domestically or you get
it outside it still comes from somewhere
so now it comes from places like russia
you know let's use it as an example
and
do you think russia or china for example
is going to be a cleaner producer of oil
and gas and electricity
no
they don't do things that way
right so when we had domestic production
that met our needs and we were a net
exporter instead of an importer things
were a lot better than the price of oil
and gas and you know producing products
because a lot of [ __ ] by the way is made
from oil and gas like plastics like the
plastic wrapper on this is made from
petroleum products for example
it's funny there is a picture somebody
uh showed earlier today of some
protester at a english football game
uh who had something on his shirt along
the lines of you know protesting oil and
gas you know industries and gas and you
know the environment sort of stuff and
he zip tied himself to the goal post
now i don't know if you guys know this
but zip ties are made from plastic which
is an oil and petroleum product dude is
like literally protesting companies and
securing themselves to the goal post
with things that those companies
manufacture so this is the insanity that
a lot of these people have is they don't
realize okay well you know you can be
all warm and fuzzy and try to save the
baby seals by stopping or significantly
reducing oil and gas production
domestically and getting it from
somewhere else like saudi arabia or
russia or something like that or
venezuela but that's a problem
right so the government knows this
right
they know what happens i mean they're
not stupid we think they're stupid but
we know
but we know that they know what they're
doing you know for the most part it's
just that they're incompetent as a whole
because people vote for incompetency in
big government you want to solve a lot
of these problems by voting vote for
small government vote for more personal
freedom vote for more accountability
that's basically the concept of um
libertarianism right liberalism
socialism is more about state control
and bigger government and
free [ __ ] you know um somebody once said
uh people people in the west don't want
freedom they want free [ __ ] now right
and that's basically what they vote for
so you can see those patterns so back to
the point of becoming independent
take control of your food supply take
control of your supply whatever you can
do take take control that as much as
possible because the more you rely on
the government for that [ __ ]
the more you're going to pay the
consequences down the road hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you